[Musique]
depuis samedi ces policiers s'assurent
de là
des voyageurs en provenance d'un pays à
risque contraint de se placer en
quarantaine 22 heures sur 24 pendant
cette période
sous peine d'une amende allant jusqu'à
1500 euros profondément choqué ce sont
les mots prononcés par la ministre des
armées à la lecture d'une tribune dans
laquelle prennent position des généraux
à la retraite
j'ai demandé au chef d'état-major
d'armes et de faire le recensement des
éventuels militaires d'activé qui
pourrait être signataires de cette
tribune afin que les sanctions qui sont
prévus soit appliqué face à des
comportements qui sont inacceptables
thalamus parler de sanctions les
sanctions
alors écoutez on est plus en démocratie
for me le dire parce que moi je suis un
civil - je suis plus un militaire je
suis la retraite
alors si maintenant en tant que civil
j'ai pas le droit d'écrire une lettre
ouverte à barr écoutez moi j'attends
qu'une seule chose
chiche com met au trou une semaine plus
tôt c'était vous qui appeler à
l'insurrection et eux ils appellent au
soulèvement contre l'islamisme vous avez
allumé la mèche
là je sais pas si c'est moi qui allumait
la mèche mais ils se sont sentis
autorisés par la taille d'un ancien de
la fée ne trouvez pas que la mèche je
sais des gens d'en face qui en eut
allumé la mâche et les généraux se
trompent d'ennemi au lieu de prendre le
virus ils prennent le gouvernement est
un général qui se trompent d'ennemi
c'est pas un très bon professionnel
quand même donc je trouve que
aujourd'hui bon il faut prendre ça avec
une certaine distance
l'appel qu'il y a dans cette tribune où
il ya plus ou moins un appel factieux au
putsch et qui menace pour la république
et je pense qu il est impératif d'y
répondre alors d'y répondre avec le des
sanctions administratives dit répondent
aussi sur le terrain du pénal il faut
donc soit châtier les coupables et nous
demandons le châtiment des coupables
nous demandons que le garde des sceaux
fasse son travail
je suis frappé de ce mépris de cette
violence que j'entends qu'elle vienne de
monsieur mélenchon ne m'étonne pas
beaucoup lui quand il s'agit de taper
sur les militaires emilie mais beaucoup
plus d'énergie que pour taper sur les
islamistes il a fait ses sweats sur
cette tribune un sûr
l'attentât terroriste de rambouillet et
moi parce que je suis milite moi je suis
parce que je suis militaire je suis
militaire de je suis militaire génomique
et la double de la vente
j'ai fait des gestions des choses à dire
et je fais des choses terribles dans ma
vie et on voudrait maintenant me
condamner pour je ne sais pas quoi mais
bon
et madame on ne sut pas sérieux quand
même ce qu'il dit c'est que si l'état ne
fait rien on en arrivera à une explosion
donc à une guerre civile
et quand réaction ça provoquera
l'intervention de nos camarades d'activ
une intervention qui viserait à la
protection de nos valeurs
civilisationnelles ce qu'ils disent
c'est que l'islamisme menace notre
civilisation que si ça continue il y
aura une guerre civile ce qui obligera
l'armée à intervenir
à aucun moment ils ne disent que l'armée
interviendra d'elle-même à aucun moment
ils n'appellent à l'insurrection
mais je vais aller plus loin qui est à
faire trembler les murs de ce studio
je pense qu'on est dans un processus de
colonisation
ils viennent dire qu' il faut faire
appliquer les lois voilà ce qu'ils
disent
nous vous demandons d'appliquer les lois
mais qu'est ce que je leur réponds je
leur réponds que je partage dans la
fiction je partage leur constat
l'engagement des militaires il est fondé
d'abord sur la neutralité notamment
politiques mais aussi et surtout sur la
loyauté et marine le pen aspire à
devenir un jour chef des armées
président de la république chef de
l'état
elle vient de se disqualifier marine le
pen est disqualifié pour devenir un jour
chef des armées en montrant qu'elle ne
comprend pas le mode de fonctionnement
et le mode d'engagement de la vie
militaire on se quitte avec cette photo
prise aux états unis un avion sur le
point d'atterrir devant la première
super lune de l'année c'est le moment où
la lune est au plus près de notre
planète